o pessoal de mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer um super carrinho que
se movimenta com a ajuda de uma l
estou fazendo este vídeo para participar
num concurso do canal do master
invenções e de química e extrema
[Música]
divulgar o concurso tem em casa com a
família ver alguns vídeos e é muito
engraçado mesmo coisa de estarem
contentes com os amigos com a câmera
andar em casa é muito giro mesmo
participando porque eu não vou ganhar
premium que não eram muito justa
o importante aqui é que vocês se
divirtam garrafa quadrada e ia a garrafa
[Música]
só que o projeto não vai ser um carrinho
cola e entre os pólos do motor porque
em seguida é só colar na parte traseira
da garrafa
a câmara quer lugar da bateria e isso
vai depender do vosso gosto eu vou fazer
uma abertura para colocar uma cadeira e
na parte da frente e fazer assim um
vidro como se fossem decapitava aprender
a bateria a bateria ao motor sem
precisar de outros filmes aqui para
conectar se você usar outro tipo de
motor é provável com certeza em
benefícios para conectar que ele destaca
é bastante simples fazer josé imputados
populam uma caixa de cereais de pequeno
almoço
vejam que o fizesse uma coisa do seu
lado para agarrar a cadeira já estava a
fazer pensar nisso
e vejam que a pilha encaixa muito bem
ficar ali neves interruptor não é
preciso filme é bastante simples mesmo
que está fora do concurso e participam
ainda vão o tempo concurso vai
realizar-se até o dia 18 oc é tão
especial as perdas no estado se vocês
quiserem ajudar o canal de voz sozinha o
favorito e se inscrevam para acompanhar
para ver no que eu faça ok
até a próxima